Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Five, Episode Six: architecture and design.
Architecture and design always reflect a society's possibilities, attitudes and values, and help make a country recognisable.
In Denmark there is a tradition of emphasising practical functions and simplicity.
You can see it already in the many village churches and half-timbered farms that, over several centuries up to the middle of the 1800s, were built on hilltops and in the landscape around the country.
It is also characteristic of the more exclusive properties which, inspired by Greek and Roman architecture, were built in the period from about 1760 to 1860, and which especially came to mark the cityscape of Copenhagen.
An example is Copenhagen's cathedral, Vor Frue Kirke, the Church of Our Lady, which was designed by C.F.
Hansen, who lived from 1756 to 1845.
It was built in the years 1811 to 29.
Parts of the cathedral are shaped like a Roman temple, while the entrance is shaped like a Greek temple front.
Today, Danish architecture and design are especially associated with functionalism, which is a way of designing where emphasis is especially placed on practical functions.
Functionalism arose in the 1920s, where it first and foremost helped to improve the poor housing standard of the towns.
In the many decades that followed, functionalism in architecture came to mark the building and shaping of the Danish welfare state, for example many Danes' homes.
One of the ideas of functionalism was that if you removed ornaments, decorations, from, for example, houses and furniture, and made them more alike and simple in expression, you also reduced their association with particular classes in society.
Functionalism's political agenda was the wish for more social equality.
In that way functionalism has become an expression of the broad Danish middle class and its modern lifestyle.
An example of functionalism is Aarhus University, which was built in 1931 to 33.
The idea behind the university was to create a kind of academic village marked by openness and harmony, and by the wish to integrate the university's many purposes into a whole.
In University Park lie the buildings that house the individual institutes such as, for example, law, history, music and political science.
But the park also contains halls of residence, a lake and streams.
Other examples of functionalism are Poul Henningsen's lamps and Børge Mogensen's furniture.
Poul Henningsen, who lived from 1894 to 1967, also called PH, was a social commentator, revue writer, film producer and architect, but became most famous for his lamp design, which made electric light glare-free.
The lamp consists of three shades, whose sizes, materials and colours can be combined in countless variations, so that the lamp creates both a pleasant and practical lighting for different purposes and prices.
In the 1940s, Børge Mogensen, who lived from 1914 to 72, developed a functionalist-influenced furniture programme for the supermarket chain FDB, now Coop, which was similarly flexible and likewise came to mark both Danish homes and town halls, schools and hospitals with a simple expression.
Arne Jacobsen, who lived from 1902 to 71, has also made a great mark on both architecture and design.
He was inspired by several different styles, not least functionalism.
Examples of his architecture are Denmark's National Bank in Copenhagen and Aarhus City Hall.
Examples of his design are the chairs the Seven, 7'eren, and the Egg, Ægget, as well as the Stelton coffee and teapots and other kitchen and serving equipment.
Danish architecture and design are today marked by great diversity and global outlook.
The architect Jørn Utzon, who lived from 1918 to 2008, was a pioneer of this development when he in the late 1950s designed the iconic opera house in Australia's biggest city, Sydney.
The building is shaped like large upright shells covered with a pattern of white tiles.
From different angles it can resemble, for example, a cathedral, sails on a ship or the waves of the sea.
This paved the way for a more experimental, expressive and playful building style, which has met great international recognition.
Currently it is continued, among others, by Dorte Mandrup, born 1961, who is behind buildings such as the Icefjord Centre at the Ilulissat Icefjord in Greenland and the Wadden Sea Centre in Ribe.
Dorte Mandrup's style is characterised by the surroundings inspiring and shaping the buildings.
Both the Icefjord Centre and the Wadden Sea Centre clearly interact with the landscapes' special characteristics and history.
Furthermore, the architect Bjarke Ingels, born 1974, and his studio BIG, Bjarke Ingels Group, have designed several prestige buildings both in Denmark and abroad.
This applies for example to Amager Bakke, also called Copenhill, which was inaugurated in 2019.
It functions both as an energy-efficient waste incineration plant and a recreational oasis with a ski slope, hiking route and climbing wall.
Functionalism, in Danish funktionalismen, is the word to remember.
Here is your recap for Episode Six.
Danish architecture and design emphasise practical function and simplicity.
Copenhagen's cathedral, Vor Frue Kirke, was designed by C.F.
Hansen and built in 1811 to 29.
Functionalism arose in the 1920s, with the political aim of more social equality.
Aarhus University was built in 1931 to 33.
Poul Henningsen, PH, made glare-free lamps.
Børge Mogensen designed furniture for FDB, now Coop, in the 1940s.
Arne Jacobsen designed the National Bank, Aarhus City Hall, and the chairs the Seven and the Egg.
Jørn Utzon designed the opera house in Sydney in the late 1950s.
Dorte Mandrup, born 1961, designed the Icefjord Centre in Ilulissat and the Wadden Sea Centre in Ribe.
Bjarke Ingels, born 1974, and BIG designed Copenhill, Amager Bakke, inaugurated in 2019.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which architect designed Aarhus City Hall together with Erik Møller?
Option A: Bjarke Ingels.
Option B: Arne Jacobsen.
Option C: Vilhelm Dahlerup.
[DA] Hvilken arkitekt har sammen med Erik Møller tegnet rådhuset i Aarhus?  A: Bjarke Ingels  |  B: Arne Jacobsen  |  C: Vilhelm Dahlerup
The answer is B: Arne Jacobsen.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Arne Jacobsen
Question 2.
Which of the following buildings did the well-known Danish architect and designer Arne Jacobsen design?
Option A: The Opera House in Copenhagen.
Option B: Christiansborg.
Option C: Denmark's National Bank.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende bygninger har den kendte danske arkitekt og designer Arne Jacobsen tegnet?  A: Operaen i København  |  B: Christiansborg  |  C: Danmarks Nationalbank
The answer is C: Denmark's National Bank.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Danmarks Nationalbank
Question 3.
Which Danish architect designed the opera house in Sydney in Australia?
Option A: Dorte Mandrup.
Option B: Jørn Utzon.
Option C: Arne Jacobsen.
[DA] Hvilken dansk arkitekt har tegnet operahuset i Sydney i Australien?  A: Dorte Mandrup  |  B: Jørn Utzon  |  C: Arne Jacobsen
The answer is B: Jørn Utzon.
It appeared in the November 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Jørn Utzon
That's the end of this part.
Well done.